[Music]
thank you
one of the important main characters in
Philip K Dick's novel The Man in the
High Castle is this person Rudolph
Wagner who is an agent an operative of
the naval counterintelligence the op
there which is a part of the German
Reich but actually one that has been
very sidelined as we'll we'll talk about
in just a moment and he is on an
incredibly important Mission and he's
traveling as he often does in Disguise
he will reveal himself eventually as
Rudolph Wagner but at first he's
traveling as Victor bains a Swedish
national who is Keen to engage with the
Pacific States of America having to do
with plastic moldings and processes he's
a businessman right and then later on
when when he's traveling back to the
Reich he is going to claim to be Conrad
goltz again another businessman and so
it's interesting to see the shapes that
this takes there's perhaps more freedom
and less scrutiny as being involved in
the economic world of business but
actually he is an operative of the Opera
and as he is going to remark a little
bit later on when they are talking about
operation dandelion the app there has
been sidelined for decades other
organizations other apparatus within the
Nazi regime have been trying to get rid
of them for years and in a certain way
this makes it possible for the op there
to be free of the other influences that
would otherwise be you know corrupting
them and their you know they're not
completely the good guys but they're
certainly better than the other Nazi
State parts
and one of the things that we see that
is really I think
revealing of Wagner's character is his
engagements with and about his uh fellow
countrymen who are in fact Nazis and the
first one takes place as he's writing
this rocket that goes from Germany to
the Pacific States of America fairly
quickly and he's sitting next to this
younger man with close cropped hair who
begins talking to him in German and Bane
says I'm sorry I don't speak German and
they're quite amazed about that clearly
the young German could not believe that
anyone in the modern world anyone who
had international business dealings and
Road who could afford to ride on the
latest Lufthansa rocket could or would
not speak German and so he asked him
well what line are you in and Jane says
Plastics polyesters resins industrial
uses no consumers Commodities and He
suggests that he can mail him a catalog
and then they get into a discussion
about art because it turns out Alex
lozza is in fact an artist he's having
his work exhibited to try to help you
know cultural exchange and Bain says I
don't care for Modern Art I like the old
pre-war cubis and abstractionists I like
a picture to mean something not merely
to represent the ideal and then Lotsa
says that's the work of art to advance
the spirituality of man over the central
your abstract art represented a period
of spiritual decadence of spiritual
chaos due to the disintegration of
society the old plutocracy the Jewish
and capitalist millionaires the
international set that supported the
decadent art those times are over art
has to go on it can't stay still and
Baines will be thinking to himself yeah
okay this is sort of a typical Nazi guy
and they get into a discussion as
they're flying down about the baseball
stadium and uh the the Nazi Lotsa is you
know laughing about this and how how the
Japanese waste their time on that and
then Lotsa says it looks about the
baseball stadium as if it was designed
by a Jew
then we have this very interesting
description Baines regarded the man for
a time he felt strongly for a moment the
unbalanced quality The Psychotic streak
in the German mind and Lotsa actually
mean what he said was it a truly
spontaneous remark and so let's pause on
that for a moment what does he actually
talking about so you know this
attribution of jewishness to anything
that is
unseemly foreign scary silly you know
whatever is non-german and is this
something that lozza just sort of throws
out there because he doesn't even have
to think about it anymore it's become a
knee-jerk habit or is this something
deliberate and here's where Baines that
is Wagner decides to do something quite
interesting
and he's provoked by some of his
Reflections which we'll talk about
elsewhere in terms of insanity and the
Nazis so he says Mr louts I have never
told anyone this I am a Jew
do you understand
you would not have known because I do
not in any physical way appear Jewish
I've had my nose altered my large greasy
pores made smaller my my skin chemically
lightened the shape of my skull changed
in short physically I cannot be detected
I can and have often walked in the
highest Circles of Nazi Society no one
will ever discover me and
there are others of us do you hear we
did not die we still exist we live on
unseen
after a moment lots of study the
security police the SD can go over my
record Bain said you can report me but I
have very high connections some of them
are Aryan some are other Jews and top
positions in Berlin your report will be
discounted and then presently I will
report you and through these same
connections you will find yourself in
protective custody and then he is near
La Lots again in fact Bain said I do not
like your looks Mr Lotus so I think I
will report you anyhow what is he doing
he's messing with him he's getting a
little bit of Revenge he's zinging him
he's putting a seed into his mind that
can't be disconfirmed he's playing to
hit the Nazi's own paranoia in chapter
five it's not Nazis that are being
encountered but there's an interesting
discussion that is going on between
tagomi and Baines and they're talking
about older people people and what the
attitude is in part because the story
the contact story is this this old
businessman is coming in and they're
supposed to arrange a situation
and so he says
um this is tagomi he says we have not in
our society solved the problem of the
age and more of which persons occur
constantly as medical measures improve
China teaches us rightly to honor the
old however the Germans cause their
neglect to seem close to outright virtue
I understand they murder the old and he
says being from Scandinavia you no doubt
have had much contact with the Fest in
Europa can one take an attitude like
this you are a neutral being Swedish
right give me your opinion if you will
and Bane says I don't understand what
attitude you mean and tagumi says
towards the old the sick the feeble the
insane the useless in all variations of
what uses a newborn baby some
Anglo-Saxon philosopher reputedly asked
I have committed that utterance to
memory and contemplated it many times
sir there is no use in general and then
tagumi says
isn't it true that no man should be the
instrument for another's needs please
give me your neutral Scandinavian
opinion and then they go forward uh
talking about the Jews again and the
Japanese attitude towards the Jews and
then finally we get sort of a reprise of
this when Wagner is returning home
and this is after all the power
struggles are taking place he's not sure
if he's going to be arrested or killed
or what's going to happen and he goes on
and as he finds out that he's he's uh
going to be taken by the SD and the
Hedrick people he says what does it
matter even if Dr goobles is to pose an
operation dandelion is canceled they
will still exist the black shirts the
parte the schemes if not in the orient
and somewhere else on Mars and Venus and
he says this is the terrible dilemma of
our lives whatever happens it is evil
Beyond Compare why struggle then why
choose if all alternatives are the same
evidently we go on from day to day we
cannot do it all at once it is a
sequence an unfolding process we can
only hope and try we don't live in an
ideal world where morality is easy where
one can do right with no effort because
we can detect the obvious and uh then he
you know questions the guards and they
reveal again uh this this uh
mindset that the Nazi regime not only
has but tends to promote in its people
now this leads naturally to talking
about the efforts to try to capture this
operative and eventually to take him out
so we find that there's two important
Nazi leaders in the Pacific States of
America we have the
fry hair Hugo rice the reichs council in
San Francisco and then we also get
kreutz Von Mera the chief of the SD the
secret Dean's height in the Pacific
States of America area and they've got
some conflicted relationships and
they're having a conversation about that
opvair character meaning Wagner and so
rice is trying to figure out what he's
talking about he says to my knowledge
there's three or four Opera characters
on the Pacific coast at the moment and
Christopher says
um
I'm talking about the one who came in by
Lufthansa within the last week and what
are they what's he doing nobody knows
and he says I'd like you to call the
foreign office and have them call the
Chancery so this is the high up and have
whoever's on hand get hold of the
admiralty and demand the app there
either take its people back out of here
or give us an account of why they're
here he says well can't you do that the
SD and he says everything's in confusion
and then rice thinks they've completely
lost this Opera man they the local SD
were told on someone by heydrich staff
to watch him they missed a connection
and they want me to bail them out and we
find out some things about him from
kreitz Von Mera that he's an
aristocratic looking fellow about 40 a
captain actual name Rudolph Wegner one
of those old monarchist families from
East Prussia probably supported Von
poppin in this system zeit and he says
the only answer I see it to these
monarchist Hangers On is to cut the
budget of the Navy so that they can't
afford and then they they basically are
going to end the conversation so what
we've got here are two different Nazi
operatives one of whom doesn't really
care that much about this but is
actually considered to be quite
competent by the Opera operative as we
find out the other is in charge of the
local police and it's kind of a a
screw-up as well and uh they're telling
us stuff about this up there fellow
namely that he's from an older
mindset one that's a bit more Humane one
that stresses Duty and honor and things
like that which are hard to come by in
the Reich then in Chapter 11
this is taken up again and uh we find
that rice is going to his office and
kreutz Von Mara is already there and he
says listen fry hair we located this
Opera fellow this real wagneri showed up
in an old op fair drop we have under
surveillance and we trailed him back to
his hotel and rice is like Ah that's
fine and kreutz Van Mayer says this is
important I notified Colton burner about
a top priority you'll probably getting
word from Berlin anytime now and uh what
ends up happening is uh they they
realize that there's a phone call this
morning about an appointment at 10 20 10
20 in the Japanese person's office we're
trying to trace the call and he says we
may pick up this fellow if we do we'll
naturally send him back to the right
however the Japs or Sacramento May
protest and try to block it they'll
protest to you and they'll run a
truckload of those tokoya Tufts to the
airport and you know he's already on the
way to the the
appointment and kreutz Von Mara says
I have a Commando Squad ready five good
men they look like violinists nice
ascetic faces Soulful maybe like
divinity students they'll get in the
Japs will think they're a string quartet
they'll walk right up to the door
they're dressed just right right in
plain sight broad daylight up to this
Wagner gather around him appear to be
conferring no violence just hair Wagner
come with us please you understand in
between the vertebrae of his spine a
little shaft pump upper ganglia
paralyzed
so they're talking about all of this and
then a phone call comes in from Berlin
and uh
rice is told this is Dr gerbils the
chancellor right and he says general
Hedrick has just asked me to call you
there's an agent of the Opera there in
San Francisco his name is Rudolph Wegner
you are to cooperate fully with the
police regarding him there isn't time to
give you details simply put your office
at their disposal so that is the setup
for the attack by the SD operatives to
try to get Wagner but also to disrupt
this meeting that's taking place and
that leads us to Wagner's mission
so he's supposed to make contact with
this agent businessman yatabe who is
actually General tedeki who is
officially retired but still plays a
very important role within the Imperial
Japanese government and there's this
scene where they both reveal themselves
and their identities to each other
they're at the Nippon Times building so
that they've got a cover for this and
that is what
has been organized so there's a lot of
waiting you know we have this reference
earlier to
um
the op vair drop Wegner is going to call
every single day and not get a hold of
the the general of course because he
hasn't come in yet and he's getting
impatient and he's getting worried so
here's from chapter 10. it had been a
terrible two weeks for Mr Baines from
his hotel roommate called the trade
Mission every day at noon to ask if the
Old Gentleman had put in an appearance
the answer had been an unvarying no Mr
tagomi's voice had become colder and
more formal each day as Mr Baines
prepared to make his 16 call he thought
sooner or later they'll tell me Mr
tagomi is out what has happened
where is Mr yatabi he had a fairly good
idea the death of Martin Borman the
party Chancellor which is shaking up
everything had caused immediate
consternation in Tokyo Mr yutabi no
doubt had been on route to San Francisco
a day or so offshore when new
instructions had reached him returned to
the home islands for further
consultation and now he has to figure
out what am I going to do
so he there's more of his internal
mental discourse it had been made very
clear to him by his superiors he was not
to contact the op Fair under any
circumstances he was simply to wait
until he'd managed to make connections
with the Japanese military
representative he was to confer with the
Japanese and then he was to return to to
Berlin but no one had foreseen that
Borman would die at this particular
moment therefore
the orders had to be superseded by more
practical advice
his own in this case since there was no
one else to consult
in the PSA at least 10 opt Fair persons
were at work but some of them and
possibly all were known to the local SD
and its senior Regional chief
Bruno kreutz from Mara so he's going to
go and
um make contact with some of the
Japanese people in the SD people as we
see in the rest of chapter 10 and then
we get this culmination in chapter 12
the revelation of operation dandelion
and this provokes a discussion between
the two principles uh General tedeki and
Rudolph Wagner neither of whom claim to
represent their governments but both of
whom
are involved and the urgency here is
that this is going to be a massive
nuclear attack preceded by a false flag
operation and The Gerbils government
since he takes power are in favor of
carrying out this attack so this
requires as Wagner says that the
Japanese government should enter into
reich's Affairs and support what they
view as the most malignant part of the
Nazi regime heydrich and the SD and SS
right
so that's uh you know quite important in
the the
understanding what Wegner is up to here
then there's an attack that's made by
the SD people we saw that Bruno Mara has
organized a squad of Commandos and they
try to assassinate Wagner and
interestingly to gomi saves him with his
World War II or actually Civil War
pistol shooting them with his Colt 44.
and there's this very interesting scene
as well that's going on so tagomi
decides to consult the eging the Oracle
to try to make sense of what happened Mr
Bain seeing Mr tagomi distractedly
manipulating the handful of vegetable
stocks recognized How deep the man's
distress was for him Mr Baines thought
this event has having to kill and
mutilate these two men is not only
Dreadful it is inexplicable what can I
say that my console him he fired on my
behalf the moral responsibility for
these two lives is therefore mine and I
accept it I view it this way and then
tadeki comes over and says you witness
the man's despair he you see was no
doubt raised as a Buddhist even if not
formally the influence was there a
culture in which no life is to be taken
all lives holy and he says the book will
help him it provides an external frame
of reference and then Baines thinks to
himself another frame of reference which
might help him would be the doctrine of
original sin I wonder if he's ever heard
of it we are all doomed to commit acts
of Cruelty or violence or evil that is
our destiny due to ancient factors our
Karma to save one life Mr tagomi had to
take to The Logical balanced mind cannot
make sense of that a kindly man like Mr
tagumi could be driven insane by the
implications of such reality
nevertheless Mr Baines thought the
crucial point lies not in the present
not either in my death or the death of
the two SD men it lies hypothetically in
the future what has happened here is
Justified or not justified by what
happens later can we perhaps save the
lives of millions all Japan in fact and
he says general
was right time would give Mr tagomi
perspective either that or he would
perhaps Retreat into the shadows of
mental illness avert his gaze forever
due to a hopeless perplexity and we are
not really different from him Mr Baines
thought we are faced with the same
confusions therefore unfortunately we
can give Mr tagumi no help so this is a
person who's really thinking profoundly
about ethical moral quandries and not
coming to easy solutions right we see
this uh coming out again as he returns
to the Reich in chapter 15 once again in
Disguise under the cover name Conrad
goltz a dealer in medical supplies on a
wholesale basis and he thinks I wonder
what I accomplished it's up to General
to Decay now whatever he can do in the
home Islands but at least we got the
information to them we did what we could
he thought but there's no reason to be
optimistic probably the Japanese can do
nothing to change the course of German
internal politics
and he's thinking about the the Nazis
and the insanity that seems to be rooted
in this ideology and in the peoples
involved and then he gets essentially
detained or arrested by these vaffin SS
men who take him and say that heydrich
is uh in the uh okw the the you know
command of the lab standard Division and
that they're not going to allow him to
be approached by Vermont or party
persons and he thinks well I'm not going
to be shot at least but what else is
going to happen and um
you know can I actually reach up fair
people in protection so it doesn't look
that way so we don't actually know what
happens ultimately to Wagner but we know
that he's alive at the end of the book
and he's succeeded in his mission and we
see all these very interesting
reflections of the kind of person he is
coming through the things that he says
and does and thinks